okay at your voice psychobabble hear ya
The Donald Shelby's in a hazmat suit
right now though then we're doing lnl
quests which is basically after you beat
the game you tracked on gang leaders a
sixsome total revenge here it'll be Mike
make them to the mattress to I think
it's out of six big mud where you at
let's tear this way man let's-- Dallas
yeah up what a lot two blocks away clean
that [ __ ] out you [ __ ] dirty you know
ya know so okay good good kid gift you
give good good good good good consistent
get get get get get okay so where is
this patch up here tree up here is
anyone no I don't think anyone actually
knows is
good God gather [ __ ] up some [ __ ]
hair that's all i gotta say my
struggling through this without any vats
no do that keep things interesting and
let me know just get some right away and
then some purified water and k and then
let me get a cool outfit on ok good good
let's do this oh [ __ ] how this is it ok
[ __ ] creepy
where is that [ __ ] hmm see we can do
here okay let's get the [ __ ] out of here
he's kinda think I fully like shotgun or
something [ __ ] insane mm-hmm and hang
it away in her lab for an hour has this
great this is great when I spent more
time changed my [ __ ] uniform and
shooting that guy up Jesus mm-hmm I
can't come on loud that loud I'll find
la I'm not allowed his ass gonna take
together samurai a lot I gotta like the
screen high up on my time USB port like
last time Jesus yeah
thanks